like this might be the coolest laptop
that i've ever seen in my entire life
it's so awesome this is a 13.3 inch oled
windows detachable laptop this cover
stand gives up to 170 degree hinge
movement it has wi-fi six you can quick
charge up to 60 in just 30 minutes
you've got dual cameras there's a 13
megapixel rear and a 5 megapixel front
fingerprint login dolby atmos and dolby
vision up to 3.3 gigahertz intel
quad-core cpu asus pen 2.0 with four
interchangeable pen tips the display has
a corning gorilla glass the keyboard is
an asus ergosense keyboard and for ports
we've got two usbc an audio jack and a
microsd card reader today i have a very
very special guest would you like to
introduce yourself to my audience and
let them know
why you're sitting here and what we have
in front of us thank you so much justine
i'm very happy to be here my name is
philip colbert otherwise known as the
lob star or the lobster very excited to
have and collaborated with asus on the
13th slate oled for me it was it's an
amazing opportunity because computers
are very much at the forefront of art
making today it seemed like a really
cool collaboration to actually really
you know get involved with the actual
computer itself and some of the
accessories which i'm excited to show
you and i'm excited because obviously
somebody who reviews a lot of tech i
love art and i also love lobsters if
some of you guys have been on my channel
for a long time you'll you'll know
exactly what i'm talking about still
thank you photos
do you see more shoes
and a lot of your art has to do with
lobsters do you want to give kind of
just a quick little i guess overview of
like why
the lobsters well i tell people that i
became an artist when i became a lobster
and i think that symbolizes to me the
freedom of art how that within within
art we can be whoever we want to be and
we can create our own worlds and we can
really push the boundaries of and
express and exercise freedom ultimately
i think in art regardless of where
people are from they can really achieve
a sense of expression a sense of
identity that maybe wasn't necessarily
there to begin with or something that
they can really create and i i love that
about art and it's a very empowering and
positive
human um you know important expression
so i guess yeah the lobster for me is my
persona my artistic persona and i think
it also underpins my belief in creating
your own world as an artist and building
like a universe and bringing people on a
sort of intellectual journey and
experience and ideally creating new
language i think of the lobster is like
putting a flag into like no man's land
in some crazy
conceptual wasteland
and then building a um an intellectual
theme park i feel like that's what you
did with this and i have not looked up
anything about this yet i mean other
than like some specs because i wanted to
have an authentic unboxing reaction and
experience to this so i guess kind of
leading into this device what was it
like for you kind of working in this
medium because you've worked in so many
different mediums like basically
spanning the entire gamut of things that
you could create i'm very interested in
in multimedia and for me that's the
phenomenon of today making art in a way
that crosses different genres and
creates a holistic
experience to art and i think certainly
working with asus has been an amazing
experience i think the level of detail
we've really put into developing the
product was very long amazing process of
just really pushing the detail i think
as we unbox you'll see that there's so
many little attention to details which
for me is there's there's so much of an
art in in product detail look at this
like every even this these details yeah
i might use it as a suitcase actually
you can take this back with you do you
think i can use it on the flight back to
london because actually you're not from
here i think i could fit the shoes in
there
you know my folded white fronts are you
ready to do the unboxing let's unbox
justine let's do it this has been
sitting here for days and i have been
waiting
to open this up i couldn't find my
machete but i have some throwing axes so
wow i think this will just one of these
open it look at that
yeah precise and that's all we needed to
do all right here we go
oh oh my goodness wait there's a little
figure too
yes there's a figure no way
that's your quote yes indeed the quote
is there so everything about this
already is awesome like i like the whole
presentation i know this is this is also
about the the product but
look how cute this is yeah i'm very
happy we made the figure i think that
was the for me the really playful way of
taking almost like a making a little
sculpture edition that interacted with
the um the pen for the pad and and
creating a a fun little crossover
between actual genuine sort of
sculptural piece and the sort of the you
know the interior scene of having the
actual laptop set up and everything is
that why his hands are or his clothes
they're in that position yeah to hold
the stylus dally made a lobster
telephone now we have a lobster pen
holder this is incredible oh my gosh i
love that so much so now we have the
viva book here
oh this is a whole oh my gosh this is
really a whole experience yeah the lots
of different things going on in there so
the device is actually in here
is this a little carrying case that is a
carrying case yes now libby the lobster
has a full lobster set for her digital
experiences this is awesome oh my gosh
like you can just hold it like that like
this is great yeah so this pattern is
obviously
my name in various sort of like brand
logo styles and then with the asus um
branding mixed in i wanted the box to be
like super fun charm box you have to
open it up what what is the charms what
is this
look at this
oh that is so difficult you attach these
to the exterior of the the laptop so
many accessories yeah you've got to see
the laptop itself okay yes
have you done an unboxing
of this yet you know i have but i think
i've only done unboxing with the
prototypes really
when they would arrive at the studio i
didn't think i've ever witnessed
necessarily a full unboxing of the final
product do you want to do this well yeah
i think your first thing is unboxing
there you go
here we go
so i think you have to do the honors on
this
okay other elements because it keeps on
like to show one
going it's just there's still more
so actually this is the um
the key component of the actual
tablet itself
oh i like this little velcro here too
that's cute this is our screen oh wow
yeah that's my signature and little
doodle of the lobster
great oh my gosh look at this yeah
that's what you attach the charms to
this is really fun it's actually like a
little sticker pack which you can then
stick onto the keyboard
customizable stickers oh that's going to
be a fun little project for later today
my kids love stickers do they have any
influence on
any of the decisions i love when my kids
are in the studio because i guess my
work is very i'm very drawn to very like
recognizable symbols and the power of
almost this poetry
these symbols that all everyone is
familiar with and very um
you know let's say loaded with meaning
the sort of holiness of the every the
power of the everyday whether it's food
objects or you know the food sort of
things or or objects that we all
interact with every day and i think
these things have are dripping with
poetic meaning so my kids also love the
connection of these a bit like cooking
you know you take two symbolic ideas and
putting them together and it creates a
little explosion i like to go and like
get everything out and see what we're
working with oh more stickers more
stickers yes i don't even know where to
start okay let's unbox them freeze the
lobster
i always like to smell things yes yeah
oh that reminds me of my childhood like
that smell one it's amazing unbox like a
fresh toy do you want to smell it just
yeah just give it yes
that's a genuine lobster okay now we
have officially unbox everything so what
do we have here where's the pen for the
lobster we've missed something there's a
whole other little section we've got our
power adapter yeah we needed the power
adapter and here is the most important
so now we have everything unboxed we've
got the little stylus and that is what
the little lobster is going to hold yes
so i'm just going to do you need an axe
yes that would be a great idea an axe
for the pen careful because it is very
sharp typing in the shining
voila okay here we go we got a pen look
at that so the pen sits in there and
then there's also do you know this is
the other thing that goes on the pen
there's so many little accessories i
feel like this would be if this is like
your first device that you've ever got
you're gonna be let down severely
everything after this because there's so
much
fun little accessories look at that it's
like a little flag so the next vital
step we attach
this guy on here and then we
can open her up like so
and so that's just like our little back
to keep it yes that's a little back and
then have your
you stick him here where do these go
these charms go on the back computers
people love to customize you know make
add their own things and play around
with it a bit but i feel like i want a
little lobster here are you left or
right-handed right okay
very well placed
nice there we go so i'm not going to put
you through me putting every single
sticker right now
enjoy doing that later but i will be
definitely doing this later which is
going to look so cool because you have
one for every single key and that's
going to completely turn this into an a
very unique experience so like devices
like this i feel like are changing the
way that people are able to create
because before i feel like you had to be
at home you had to be in your studio you
had to have all of your stuff where you
could basically be anywhere creating and
doing things with devices like this
completely i find i spend um so much
time when i'm traveling you know with
with the tablet and the pen just you
know drawing on on the tablet it's
amazing these tablets are in a way
mobile creative studios and which is
amazing the fact that i mean one of the
the remarkable things about technology
has it's made the artistic practice so
democratically accessible and you know
how you can create and upload your work
immediately on online it's pretty
remarkable it's so fascinating so even
like working kind of in this medium like
what was your biggest challenge well i
think always the challenge with when one
is
making you know let's say in brand
collaborations with art is obviously
making sure everyone doesn't lose the
integrity of one's work in in the
collaboration but i think with asus the
you know i was really happy with the
fact that we could really put so much
work into the detail yeah i mean even
the case too oh my gosh like everything
just it's just fun but what was really
exciting about the project is because i
have a metaverse i think probably the
world's biggest artist metaverse on
decentraland so i have my own city
lobsteropolis and so we created an asus
colbert store in um in lobsteropolis
where we had product displays and
everything in the metaverse and for the
opening of the um the launch of the
laptop we had a full big event i think
like a thousand different lobster
avatars turned up and and what's amazing
is i love the the fact that the laptop
itself is obviously a gateway to my
metal to my metaverse so i'm going to be
going more in depth in this laptop
giving you guys a closer look at all of
the details since you're here let's talk
more about your art and kind of how you
got started because i'm actually a new
fan of your art despite being you know
someone that would never did very well
at school or anything i always had a
malfunctioning
you know in my wiring that was like i
could do anything and well i could just
believe that anyone could do anything
and it wasn't that i was special or had
any particular skills beyond anyone else
i was just you know what i think
if you set your mind on something and
you work hard at it i think anyone can
do anything so i always had that belief
if i work hard at something
and you know i have i believe in it then
it'll happen speaking of journey and
kind of going into another dimension i
mean you definitely took this vivo book
into another dimension and i'm so
excited about it and i look forward to
everyone else checking out this and your
art so thank you so much for joining us
well thank you so much for having me
it's been a pleasure this is so fun and
his little mini lobster convention is
there anything else you want to let them
know like where they should find you
they've brought a small gift for you as
well but but i don't know whether we
need to have it on thing but i mean we
might as well well first of all just to
go with your with your asus pen holder
no you a
also
this is actually for libby the lobster
oh i'll have to give it to libby next
time i see her okay as as part of the
lobster fraternity
yes okay i was just gonna say because
your chain was so freaking cool
i'm i'm the cardinal lobster and you're
sort of the gold okay like you're going
to create
walking around los angeles okay well i
mean i have to give it to libby not this
is not for me yes you can share it this
is so cool oh wow this is like the best
day ever thank you so much do you want
to let them know where they can find you
online you have to come check out the
metaverse of lobsteropolis in
decentraland ideally through the asus
collaborative lobster laptop and yes so
check out lobsteropolis and um and also
the art project love stars i think it'll
be really fun for you guys to see
the um the crazy world of lobsters this
is so exciting oh my gosh well thank you
so much i'll give you a high five
hi
claw five is that is this a cloth is
that right
high claw a high tool
yes
[Music]
i had so much fun interviewing philip
about his art and his collaboration on
this vivobook 13 slate oled so now i'm
even more excited to do a little
customizing of my own with all of these
really cool stickers i did get a little
head start so i have a few stickers here
already but i need to put all of these
on to the actual keyboard so i am just
so excited to put these stickers on
let's go
oh no
what have i done i didn't mean to do
that oh no
the good news is these aren't super
sticky so they're very easy to put on i
was worried for a second that this was
going to be very difficult it's actually
not
[Music]
we did it we did it all of the keys are
covered and they look incredible i've
still got a few more stickers here so i
think i might just put
this little eggy right here i also think
that i want to switch out this little
yellow
mesh for the red because why because we
can let's pop off our little charms and
let's
see
how this works
snap our little charms back on i love
the red this looks great
there you go hold on to my stylus so
here's what it looks like and this is
the removable stand
this is just magnetic
and oh look at that a little surprise
lobster
there's so many surprises you just never
know what this laptop is going to bring
to you and this is just magnetic so this
snaps right on to the back which allows
you to put it in different positions
right up here is your fingerprint sensor
and the power button so this is a nice
little one touch login which is super
easy and convenient and oh my goodness
even the actual desktop background when
you start this up it even has a phillip
colbert look to it we've got the eggs
we've got our little lobster now this is
a magnetic keyboard as well this pops
right off just like so so you're able to
use this as a tablet or if you want to
use the keyboard you just
snap it back on and extend the little
back hinge and you're now in laptop mode
i really love two-in-one devices like
this because there are times when i'm
watching content and i don't even need a
keyboard and i can just detach this just
like so and i can use this as a tablet
and it's nice too because i can even
take off this back magnetic cover so we
don't even need to have this on it is
kind of cool because you can just flip
it around and you can rotate it so you
can use it in different views which is
quite nice we're gonna flip it back
around we've got our little stylus here
so we need to connect our stylus and
it's really cool because when you just
pull this out just like that this will
give you access to your usb-c port so
that you're able to charge it and get it
set up with your device another thing
that is really cool is i showed you guys
this during the interview but this is
the little sleeve that you can use i
love that this also has so many cool
designs on it it's very very custom
and i promise you there's not going to
be many people if you walk into a coffee
shop that is going to have the same
laptop as you so it is definitely a
conversation starter so let's see what
it looks like inside of
here
so inside here we've got two little
sides which is nice because you can
probably fit a few other things in there
perfect fit
and there it is
i love this thing so much it's so cool
i didn't even see the bottom of the
keyboard look it even has the little lob
circle bear logo on it too
how many secrets are hidden in here how
many things are on this laptop that i
didn't even get a chance to even realize
were on here i don't know if you guys
want to get more information about the
vivo book 13 slate oled i'll put a link
in the description a huge thank you to
asus for partnering with me on this
video and a huge thank you to philip for
hanging out and chatting with me and not
only talking about his art but the
thought process and creation that went
into creating this view of book 13 slate
oled i am so excited to get a chance to
play with this device more and i'm even
more excited that i got to give you guys
this inside look at what went into
actually creating this beautiful
artistic masterpiece this is so fun and
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and i
will see you guys in my next one if you
guys are new here hi i'm justine welcome
to my channel thanks for watching i do a
lot of different types of videos mostly
focusing on tech reviews if you guys
want to subscribe hit subscribe hit the
bell so you'll be notified when i post
new videos and leave me a comment below
and let me know what kind of videos are
your favorite and also if you were a
lobster what kind of outfit would you
wear i'm very into this little matching
suit jacket and pants combo
love it
[Music]